you are not my hero  and i'm not here so you can sign my oar  i'm here cause you stole the heart of  davidi  and you will board my boat welcome back  to the things disney fans  moana is one of the most daring disney  princesses out there  using her skill and bravery to save the  day but what would it look like if she  were an  evil goddess instead of the hero of the  story we're imagining how her eyes  hair face and outfit would change if she  used her power over the  ocean for bad rather than good even the  sky would alter after she harnessed the  power inside her necklace to wreak havoc  on everything around her that would be  one scary day right  poor pua the pig would be terrified of  the new  mean moana  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  um  [Music]  oh  yeah  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you